what you can see here and we've got four
at the moment are combinations of these
same three factors okay x x minus two
and x plus one okay now with all three
of these no matter how you combine them
if you just multiply all of them if you
multiply a couple of them and divide or
multiply one and divide by the other two
or switch them around because they're
the same factors they will go through
the same regions does that make sense so
we're going to do is because i've done a
lot of the work for you this is going to
go quite quickly but you'll see how it
behaves across all of them so
stay with me now
perfect let's have a look at the first
one okay now this guy is just a cubic
it's just a cubic it'll be x cubed and
some x squared and some x's and some
constant right so therefore because i
have to pass through here i know that
these three are all just intercepts does
that make sense and so you get a
familiar cubic shape something like
that
and there's really nothing else much
else to it right i must pass through
these regions
and i must pass through these intercepts
and that's all there is to it and we've
seen cubics like this before this is not
too super dramatic okay so that's a
cubit
but where it starts to get really fun is
where you start dividing by some of
those things okay so for instance here
have a look right now it's already
factorized let's do the next step sf
a for asymptotes right what asymptote do
you see here
okay x is equal to zero that's a
vertical asymptote
okay
now later on i will show you how to find
the fact that there's another asymptote
here um it's oblique and its equation
which we won't worry about at the moment
is x minus one so i've got a line going
across
like this
okay
i'll show you how to determine that
later you don't have to be too concerned
about that right now but
i've done my asymptotes uh y equals x
minus one i've got an asymptote here x
equals zero okay
what was my other step s f a
i for intercepts where are the
intercepts where do i get intercepts
from
from the
i get them from the numerator don't i i
get vertical asymptotes from the
denominator and i get
intercepts from the numerator they're 2
and negative one
two
and negative one
i've already put my regions in here now
so where could a graph possibly go that
goes through these regions approaches
these asymptotes and intersects with
those intercepts
outside of the
so yeah
and to the top of the
and
reflected on the other side okay almost
reflected almost you're getting
something like this
okay that's a look that looks a little
weird doesn't it but can you see
there's no other place the graph can go
right like how else could it pass
through this intercept and go through
these regions and approach these
asymptotes where else are you going to
wiggle around right yeah does that mean
it doesn't always have to go like
towards asking for it because in this
one it's like kind of stopping
will it ever cross
which ascent are you talking about the
vertical or the oblique the oblique one
yes well that line that you're on right
now will it ever cross the y-axis
the y-axis the y-axis
no it cannot because and this is
something i'm alluding to my my one of
my later on examples will show this okay
a vertical asymptote because like i said
it has to do with domain
right
you there is no way you can put x equals
zero into it so this could never like
break in over here and then come across
the other side right for two reasons
number one the vertical asymptote bars
its way
right number two like this region is not
shaded i can't go there the factors
dictate that i have to stay on this side
if i want to be over here it's going to
be above the axis because of the region
that i shaded that you guys shaded for
me
okay
all right let's move to this guy okay
again same factors right let's do the
asymptotes first vertical ones easier so
what can you see from the denominator
x equals try to be more precise okay i
know z i know what you mean but be
precise it's x equals zero and x equals
negative one so there's x equals
negative one
and here is x equals zero
okay
that was a vertical asymptote do i have
a horizontal or an oblique asymptote
how can we tell the way that i work out
whether it's horizontal or oblique is i
compare the degrees of the top and the
bottom degrees at the top and bottom now
the degree here is one the degree here
is two so crude way of thinking about it
is this is going to grow but this guy's
going to grow so much faster right so
when you take the quotient
you're going to approach 0. is that okay
so i'm going to get a horizontal
asymptote here of y
equals 0. can you see why it's more
helpful to be precise and say x equals 0
y equals three they're different
completely different
okay now
i need an intercept don't i because it
was s f a i for intercept
what intercepts would you like me to
work out so there's not going to be any
so there's not going to be more precise
there's not going to be a y-intercept
because if i put in x equals 0 i'm
busted
so there's no
y-intercept right
but there is an x-intercept where do i
get x-intercepts from
i get them from the numerator x is going
to be
two now hold on a second
hold on hold on hold on
how do you define what's the definition
of an asymptote
now
one way of defining an asymptote
is to say oh it's a line you can't touch
or you can't cross but there's a problem
with that it's a little bit like saying
um
it's a little bit about saying prime
numbers are like numbers that are
factorized by one of themselves but one
is not prime right so it's like a
close definition but not quite okay
what's an asymptote really an asymptote
is some kind of line that you are
approaching approaching right now in
normal circumstances you would never
actually touch the line because that's
what approaching means you're getting
closer but you never get there okay but
tell me tell me where horizontal and
oblique asymptotes i gave you a word
right that told you where these guys are
important
and i gave you some values that would
tell you where they are what was the
starts with e
extremities right at the positive and
negative ends right so therefore
horizontal and oblique asymptotes
what relevance do they have to the
middle of the graph answer
none
they just tell you about what's
happening over here so now when you look
at this guy right you're like okay i
have this horizontal asymptote but right
there right there he's blowing right
through it and he can
this horizontal asymptote in fact you'll
see some people who um
they graph i need a piece of paper
they graph like this they kind of do
their horizontal asymptotes here and
here because that's really where the
horizontal asymptotes are important now
i don't recommend you do that because it
just it just looks weird okay it's like
the line keeps going right it's not like
i just start this bump somewhere i think
this is a better way to do it but it
does capture the fact that this
horizontal asymptote or this oblique
asymptote right like look in here for
instance this one we graphed before see
that see that is the line is the
function approaching the oblique
asymptote in here
answer no it's running away as fast as
it possibly can the oblique asymptote
only takes over at the extremities does
that make sense question why is y 0
why is y 0 or an asymptote because as i
think about what happens when i put
large values positive or negative values
of um
into x right into x then i'm going to be
approaching for example this would be
like say a thousand over a million
which is going to get closer to zero
it'll be a million over a million
million which will be approaching zero
all right yes last question why is the
second graph like the answer to y equals
two x minus one
hold on
this graph you turn that one yeah
i will talk about how to find the
oblique asymptote
afterwards i will just i'll tease the
fact that remember when we looked at
this guy right the way that i knew that
this was the oblique asymptote is
because i saw the part that disappeared
and this is all that i have left
right so so how do you do that though
like i presented it to you i will show
you okay but i don't there are just so
many ideas that you need to wrap around
okay
so let's have a look at this guy
i think it's easiest to do the easy bits
first and then we'll leave the harder
installation have a look on the left
hand side over here i have to stay in
this region
i have to obey these two asymptotes so
what's it gonna do
it's just gonna yeah it's just gonna
it's got nowhere else to go
where else can it go right it can't it
can't cross this vertical asymptote
it can't cross this horizontal one
because the region tells it not to
you see how powerful this is right it
locks in where you are have a look at
this next one in here have a look in
here right look i've got two vertical
asymptotes here
so i'm fenced in
and i've got a um i've got a region that
says you can't go anywhere in there
right so this is what i've got
where else can it go question other way
around is that fine
can we have it like upside down you mean
you mean like this
well
can it be upside down
and the answer is it can't because then
it would have to stop somewhere right
now this graph it has discontinuities as
you can see but they're not
discontinuous like that step graph we
said before where it's like okay i'm
telling you stop now right
this just goes everywhere it possibly
can so it's going to get arrows right if
it's got arrows and they're facing
downwards like this then the arrows are
going to break through here and they're
going to break out of my region which i
can't do that's what the whole point of
the regions is
make sense
all right hardest part now
we've got this to deal with okay
now let's just think link think in terms
of what you know think in terms of what
you know i have an intercept here and i
have negative to positive negative to
positive you agree with that
so i'm going to have to come up through
here right i'm gonna have to come up now
obviously if i think about now going
towards the left i'm approaching this
negative this sorry this vertical
asymptote so i'm going to be going
downwards like that like i'd have to go
further down to actually get closer like
you'll see why i have to do this shake
okay so i'm going to get down
like that to approach this aspen tote
don't move
but what's going to happen over here on
the right
well okay what's it going to do it has
to it has to go up like this line it
can't just decide to like a sharp like
an absolute value it can't just turn
around like that okay so it has to go up
some distance
but we've already determined that at
positive infinity it's going to come
toward this guy
so it has to
turn
around
and then approach
that looks weird right but it can't do
anything else it must it has no choice